the gyro can experience yeah but the
thing is Seagal was a legit Aikido
specialist like if it was just Aikido
like that's what people just because a
guy seems kind of silly you forget like
he had a real legit history it with a
key no he was the first American to ever
ever teach at a dojo in Japan speaks
fluent Japanese and he's a legitimate
Aikido master like 100% absolutely'
chittim and Aikido master
the thing is Aikido is just not
something that translates perfectly to
to MMA
what is this Seagal best Aikido with
Russian national Aikido team yeah bro
I'm not bullshitting man his Aikido is
100% legitimate well you see I would
have I would like almost discredit
everything just based on that one parody
thing you know a joke that should show
of a joke yeah but I mean break the
wrist walk away but this is all nonsense
someone's gonna give you their armor but
if they did he would [ __ ] you up better
than this because this is Seagal as an
older man who's overweight go to Steven
Seagal when he was really young there's
black-and-white footage of him teaching
at a dojo in Japan there it is he is a
hundred percent legit and Kito's not the
best martial art for self-defence it's
just not but it has its applications and
in its applications he's a master at it
much like jiu-jitsu has its applications
but it's not great for kickboxing right
yeah Taekwondo has its applications but
it doesn't work if you kick the legs and
punch the face yeah but if you learn how
to do it those techniques can apply if
you know all the other stuff well if you
know all the other stuff this
[ __ ] has some real [ __ ] it's
just whether or not you would have to be
so good at all the other stuff that you
could utilize this I know obviously he's
showing in this tech thing he's showing
knife defense and stuff like that but
this is all 100% legit technique he's
good man I mean not good not good he's
outstanding his Aikido is outstanding
the real question is how effective is
Aikido yeah
I'm still like I can't get past the the
joke of the front cake and it's hard to
get past that part but I didn't know
this it's hard to get past someone who
doesn't have
an objective understanding of how people
view them yeah like I just me and George
CPA Georgie Pierre wanted to learn how
to throw a turning sidekick for me
you're an animal at that by the way I
felt embarrassed teaching him though
because I'm just a comedian yeah and I'm
a you know I'm a commentator but I was
like I know this sounds crazy that I
really know how to do it and then when I
did it he was like holy [ __ ] I was like
yeah this is what I used to do so but
but me showing him that I mean I'm under
no illusion that I could kick George st.
Pierre asked you what [ __ ] me up every
day of the week but I was like I have
this one thing that I can show you that
I bet you can't do the way I can do it
and I can show you how to do it but I'm
not like you know like what Cevallos
doing like so that's a front kick man
front kick you know and even a spinning
back kick you can teach someone it but
having them having the confidence to
confidence to execute that to choose to
do that like you're in a situation the
guys come forth you choose to spin you
got to be so rock solid we our
understanding of that technique you're
not gonna get that without years and
years and years and years and years of
drilling it that could be a death
sentence you know in a live combat
fistfight yeah so even like when I throw
some times I'm like man I throw a lot of
[ __ ] man like I do like the tornado
kicks and [ __ ] no yep and uh and I do
like I did one time to page on this
fight where he came at me and I stepped
back and I did like a hopping spinning
back-kick like the one Uriah Hall hit
Gegard Mousasi with oh yeah I did that
but it hit him like right on the belt
not exactly where I wanted to hit to
land and a pitcher my foot slides now it
looks like I kicked him in the balls but
it was like right above like the belt
line I mean if I just got a little bit
more to the side i'm in the heel i would
have probably dropped do you practice
that like in front of the bag oh yeah
but then i will have someone holding the
shield mm-hmm and can I just you know
for like 20 minutes yeah I just having
like control like I'm like yo I want to
have like a stationary target but also
somewhat moving so it's more practical
because no one's just gonna stand in
front of me like hey just spinning
back-kick me to the ribs
[Applause]